away we go Jesus Christ the good was a
good test speak favor no mm-hmm you
point does that mean we're ready to go
hey check me out on the camera hi you're
listening to the dollop on the all
things comedy Network you can check out
the video of this podcast on youtube at
all things comedy yeah Gareth yeah Dave
you know our jumping right in the biz
you know hiring is difficult oh god you
don't need to tell me a gear core I mean
what a nightmare it's been yeah you guys
have nightmare here let me tell you
we're in the red it's a nightmare
there's one place where you can go or
hiring is simple it's fast and it's
smart
a place where growing businesses connect
to qualified candidates in that place is
zip recruiter dot-com slash dollop I
feel like you told me about this before
and I floated it up to myself and
something happened with Garrett core
that must've been oh yeah we got a bad
you got a bad board situation over there
you also got bad management which you
could all find at zip recruiter okay zip
recruiter sends your job to earth a
hundred of the web's leading job boards
but they don't just stop there care core
I'm speaking to care call right now with
their powerful matching technology zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right experience
and invite them to apply to your job at
care core wait what do you guys what
kind of people you hiring right now
again we're looking for all types we're
looking for you know people who are good
at you know accounting management and
you know anybody who's able to sort of
you know kind of cross a lot of T's and
you know you think that needs to be
cross crossing anything that needs a dot
give it a dot this all sounds really
really not focused
maybe zippers can help you out with that
as applications come in super critter
analyzes each one and spotlights the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match so effective that eighty percent
of employers who posted on on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the first day so
we're talking first day for care court
we need to do because that's huge I've
been thinking about doing an undercover
boss and I guarantee they can find a lot
of cat lifters because I know you got a
problem with that with high results like
that it's no order no wonder that zip
recruiter is the highest rated hiring
site in America and now our listeners
can try zipper kurtter for free at this
exclusive web address zip recruiter comm
/ dollop that sip recruiter comm / stop
do llo p you know you know me zip
recruiter Tom / dollop zip recruiter the
smartest way to hire and gear core
making dreams realities kind of what we
need a slogan guy tip you you need a lot
of guy yeah called it quote is
jam-packed sip arguments
there's a lot of swearing in that and I
want to apologize to any of the nuns
listening who don't swear and they get
upset with that kind of thing that I
recall from Catholic school okay I'm not
going to Catholic school for two years
sure and sister Katherine once I had we
haven't somewhat the podcast us yet it's
the doll this is a rocking history
podcast each week right I read a story
for American history to my friend Gareth
Reynolds who has no idea what the topic
is going to be about now the business is
out of way let's have some fun
um yeah I mean we were there was a book
and I just add a lot of swear words and
and sister Katherine found it and I got
a lot of trouble I'd like put dick and
balls just I added added words and it
was a book that were reading an English
class but I added put some Flair in sure
notes for the author cuz I didn't think
Herman Melville really knew what he was
doing you mean Herman balls Melville
boom
Gareth yes Dave the the this podcast the
dollop is also brought to you by Mack
Weldon a premium premium premium men's
essential brands that believes in smart
design and premium fabrics and we love
it love them like it's not even yeah
it's it's a it's the real deal with us
and they'll last the apocalypse
yeah I know that was probably gonna
probably gone on a limb but that's not
that's not their guarantee it's what we
think I talked to them over there
Garrick we reached out you're gonna in
the apocalypse you'd be like it's
finally I meant Mac well Vince yeah and
that'll be all you'll have you got a
motorbike like you know eating the heart
of your enemy yeah yeah
does it fit nicely so bit yeah soft the
right amount of thickness and softness I
don't know how they did it it's
ridiculous NASA they believe it smart
design premium fabrics and simple
shopping Mac well there will be the most
comfortable underwear socks shirts and
undershirts hoodies sweat pants and more
than you ever wear they have a line of
silver underwear shirts that are a
naturally antimicrobial which means they
eliminate odor which I know is good for
you
you know just one of the things you need
yeah right they want you to be
comfortable and if you don't like your
first pair you can keep it and they'll
still refund you the money right that's
so that's in crazy
yeah no question said then I can ask
questions you're not gonna go what's
what's going on what did you do with
them
not only do Mac Wheldon's underwear over
and see you in him no they're not gonna
do that
that's your job give us your address at
home not only do Mac Weldon's underwear
socks and shirts look good they perform
well too it's good for working out going
to work going on dates everyday life
where uh I'm gonna say right now we're
boxer briefs boxer brief guy what about
you say I'm gonna take them all I'll
show you show me show you present let's
present to me that's kind of like an
order sir give it to me look you're a
little turned on by it you're like oh my
god this boy yeah so it's super you just
go on the website it explains the
different kind of got like four and four
different types of the underpants that's
that's pansy you put on underneath your
pants well that makes sense I've been
wearing them outside
um super easy to use super easy to get
just comes to your door you don't have
to chase down a truck or anything like
other other companies share so for
twenty four percent up twenty four
twenty percent twenty percent off your
first order visit McClellan comm and
enter promo code dollop at checkout
that's Mack Weldon comm promo code out
for twenty percent off your first order
we love them yep
last but not least today's show is
sponsored by talk space the online
therapy company lets you message a
licensed therapist from anywhere at any
time all you need is computer with an
internet connection or talks based
mobile app that means you can improve
your mental health even if you've had
trouble making time for it in the past
which you may you make because you may
have a very demanding job yeah you might
be putting your name on everything or
you don't like the waiting room cross
over daughter's booze a little weird
what's happened something happen
sometimes you talking about you talking
abou become fertile situations like on
TV you tell she's a little that she's
attractive and it's on it's not cool
because she's your daughter
wait look a lot of people are freaked
out right now
depressions up high
highly up there's it's it's hard for a
lot of people with what's going on it's
weird to have a fascist government
taking over so so you can do this if you
can't if you don't have a lot of time
for therapy I've gotten a lot of
messages from a lot of people who have
said are saying this is very much help
them which is why we keep working with
them because it is genuinely nice it's
about a guy and his daughter it just
sort of oh the guy who wants to yeah he
should he should call he should get into
talk space he should start working on
talk space because he wants to have
seems like you might want to do stuff
with his daughter but this that isn't
just about that you can call it every
again you can stuff off your chest you
want to talk about challenges of work
whatever chat about life remember
therapy isn't just about venting your
innermost thoughts or digging into
childhood memories it's also about
practical everyday strategies for stress
management and living a happier life
having if they're simply provides you a
designated person for you to talk to who
is trained to listen and help you make a
positive changes the talk space platform
has over two thousand licensed
therapists who are experienced in
addressing life challenges we all face
to match with a perfect therapist for a
fraction of the price of traditional
therapy go to talk space.com slash stop
and use the code dogs you have forty
five dollars off your first month and
show you support for this show that's
dollop and tuck space.com slash dollop
like I said we even get messages from
people who've got a lot of positive
feedback yeah for sure
David we are on tour you can go check
out the dollop podcast.com and then
click on tour schedule you can find out
where we're gonna be I'm going on the
road a little bit I'll be at a helium in
st. Louis the 26th of July through the
28th the following weekend I will be at
the punchline in San Francisco that's
the first weekend of August and then the
next weekend I will be at helium in
Portland so that's fun
and I'll be there our next big dates are
Salt Lake City on July 20th Denver on
the 21st boom boom let's just get right
into this well actually wait wait wait
wait no that's not the intro for two
notes it's not the intro second I feel
like
it might be a good time to do the thing
we do every now and then I'd you see all
of the day no no where I work no no
where I take where I'll let me I'll do
one let's do a rollup or a polit as
they're called I have one let's do a
reverse let's do a reverse dollop I have
one right here it doesn't matter
let's have a reverse dollop David let's
have a reverse dollop shut up
and as you know I have different rules
I'm allowed to go anywhere in the world
whereas you are for some reason shackled
to America oh and the 17th are we do in
that show in Glendale apologize yes oh
my god oh and this Sunday I'll be at the
improv sorry ball shyest I said they're
fascists secondly we are doing a show on
the set I should look at the name of it
but it's a basic initiative yet we're
doing a show for the Glendale tenants
Union obviously people are having a lot
of problems with crazy rent these days a
lot of people can't afford rent that's
actually bad because if you can't afford
rent you live in the street you got to
do things like gentleman recycles over
fountains to just get by sure
so I mean another guy putting together a
night of comedy for for the Glendale
tenants Union and that's to try to get
something going where it's just things
are better that's July 17th at the name
well we got momentum with the bralette
doing it momentum yeah solid I hate this
podcast yeah no people are complaining
on Facebook about this plan I'm pretty
drunk what an an atheist an atheist
theater in a deist theater in Glendale
Glendale in Glendale I'll put up a thing
on the Facebook page and all you know
hit it on Twitter now hey it's me it's
me it's you it's Moshe kasher it's a
Adomian Jackie Kashian
so I got a couple of meanings in there
cuz it's a bigger meaning in town
smart Dave do me a favor and shut up
because March 19th 1922
what are you doing over the driver's
seat whoo
it's like when a kid has a learner's
permit to quit harshing my mellow pops
travis pastrana okay
hero a Noda was born in wait what are
you talking about hero a Noda that's the
guys name his name is [ __ ] hero H AI
R let's just wrap this up of the gauge I
are even have why even have one of the
years there's a lot more to this story
there's a lot more to this tell me about
your hero no you're not my hero his name
is Hiro Hiro an out here Onoda
now you're messing me up was born in the
village of Kamakahi in Japan one of my
favorite villages he always said that he
was the fifth of seven children there
were five boys two girls
how many lived all lived at the
beginning yeah yeah I know they're not
like one and two they got out of another
pipe they made it human sighs I can't I
can't guarantee that they all lived but
in 1922 the family was humming we had
five of waited five of seven so that's
seven I mean five or seven he was the
fifth of seven seven out of seven anyway
he's small but he's scrappy he said
quote I was always defiant and stubborn
and everything I did he would save his
childhood
that's like me that's very much like
your very you might hear this guy laugh
yeah yeah
in 1939 world war ii was just getting
warmed up oh I love World War two great
one I'm into this one at seventeen hero
found himself working for a lacquerware
company in China which he did to get a
chance to see the world outside of Japan
wait a minute but he's doing it Oh or
lacquerware so sure so is he traveling
with it or is it just making it in China
he's making it okay yeah but he thinks
he can make money does he think his lack
of works couldn't take him around the
world he I mean no he just wanted to
leave Japan you never left Japan China
yeah it's not a great place to be if
you're Japanese in World War two
starting don't say that right now well
he look he I mean lack of are called
so but in reality what he was really
doing was he was just killing time
because he knew within two years he
would be drafted because every male at
the age of 20 had to register for two
years of service in the Japanese army 20
yeah you could skip 18 and 19 just [ __ ]
off yeah I guess I don't know that was
weird to me too yeah I mean you start
kill him young if you can have a war
okay I mean I was turning around five
but go ahead yeah don't get in Dave's
army obviously like a young soldier oh
my god he's looking at the camera this
is what happens when you're not reading
you're just doing a little photo shoot
over there so while he was waiting for
his definite service he did what we'd
all do he danced he smoked a lot of
cigarettes and he played mahjong she
smoked around 20 cigarettes a day on but
nights when he played mahjong that
number went up to about 50 what is that
mahjong yeah mahjong it's a game what
kind of game yeah you know cards oh it's
a card game
yeah I think it is yeah hope so it's not
I'm right now picturing guys in the
field rolling balls no no no it's
nothing near it's so much closer to
cards for sure yeah okay it's not as
good
no in May 1942 hero was called up for
his army physical here we go
he passed with flying colors and he was
a Class A Banzai this essentially meant
that he was expected to give his life
for the cause of war with they just told
you that he didn't volunteer they just
said you you're a Banzai well that's
kind of where you start I said I mean I
think that's like a lower or not a
kamikaze citroen no no not a kamikaze no
no yeah yeah so but what it essentially
meant was you had to give your life
forward in the sense that you if even if
you didn't die in battle if you you were
you were expected to kill yourself
before you were captured
sure Honda still has that for their
employees absolutely I Drive a Honda
yeah which is a hard thing to time out
obviously like one of you when is it
time to kill you thank you yeah when you
do it yeah like that was just like a dog
yeah yeah my dad still going yeah know
it for sure with a little time before
his service began he wrote quit his job
and he immediately returned home to get
in better shape he spent his days
swimming in the ocean and his Knights
kendo sword fighting in a gym [ __ ] yeah
this is like me so far this is totally
one opportunity it's totally a you story
too that's I think you're gonna like
this it's really you I picture you and
now and now this guys are here all right
he's art mm-hmm hero hundred basic
training and was an immediate stand out
so much so that he was later transferred
to food Amada Japan for training with
the Devils Karuma which means the
devil's karma which is pretty badass
which is an elite class of soldier that
would be trained as such yeah he was in
a class of 200 you're still picking
yours at pictures so he's yeah so far as
my story yeah so he's like a like a
green beret type gentleman now I
wouldn't even say he's like a green
beret but he's like it is a lower he's a
beige beret yeah he's like well how does
it work in karate so before green I
think he's a purple okay it's a purple
beret Purple's are a purple gray we have
no problems with purple so he was a
class of two hundred and thirty of her
other soldiers they were packed into
classroom like sardines and it was
really revealed to them why they were
there the purpose of this branch of
school is to train you in secret warfare
they were told no good it was to be
guerilla warfare which called for
irregular tactics to fight enemy like
ambushes hit and runs and raids like so
drop this guy in Chicago what I'm saying
drop this guy in Chicago yeah I guess
but that's more like it more like a
Criss Angel thing I'm just no Chris
angles a magician yeah but what are you
asking them to do drop this cargo
haven't [ __ ] [ __ ] up and I even
understand now we fighting Japan or not
yeah but so put this guy in Chicago let
him [ __ ] turn [ __ ] loose no it's not
as like a movie preview okay okay it's
not really good yeah and paper maybe so
it also relied on more smaller groups to
do it effectively I thought you're gonna
say s'mores and it's required s'mores
yummy very good another good thing is as
a guerrilla if you were to be caught you
are not expected to kill yourself in all
all right well I'll tell you see if a
regular soldier had been taken prisoner
at some point if he was returned to
Japan he could potentially be sentenced
to death for not taking his own life
when he should have so the punishment
for not killing yourself was to be
killed by others so fun yeah okay so if
you don't kill yourself they're gonna
kill you if you don't kill yourself and
you get captured so then and then so if
you're getting captured but for the most
part the the mantra is if you're
captured
kill yourself before you're captured
because they'll get it they'll get
information out of you so if you return
home released from capture for the rest
of your life you'll be walking around
like you an [ __ ] you're a man of
shame or they'll kill you in court or
the war you'll get like you'll go to
court and they will sentence you to
death I mean these are bad options madam
but the number one option I see right
now is don't don't join the army
but go ahead mmm well again you were
forced into mm-hmm you're still
picturing yourself but as a guerrilla
that was out the window he was told you
were absolutely forbidden to die by your
own hand well what the [ __ ] it may say
it's really complicated it may take five
years but whatever happens we will come
back for you until then so long as you
have one soldier you are to continue to
lead him and then you just fall in love
with Chicago no and then what no no no
nobody's going to show yes get to see it
bands and [ __ ] bears you're like I
love the Bears right if he loves the
Bears that's gonna be a problem for this
mission so yeah he was torn because he
loved the Bears who's the enemy now he
wants to be the run and then he and then
he starts fighting a war against
Wisconsin oh my god okay this
conversation is over
for six months in the army here Onoda
learned how to conduct guerrilla warfare
with sabotage counterintelligence and
propaganda so that was the main reason
why they didn't have to kill themselves
because if they were captured they felt
like they could mislead who capped who
like took them prisoner by misinforming
them and misleading them and that in a
way was sort of like poisoning them so
that would that would sort of help their
side okay he learned there were no right
answers in guerrilla warfare quote you
do what seems best suited at the time
with the circumstance this was around
the time when the Japanese army had
gotten control of the Philippines from
the Philippines and the American forces
the Philippines already had but the
American forces were there but Japan
needed control of it between the u.s.
army because they needed they needed the
Philippines so that there was no way
America could get a direct route in de
Jero Sorrell so we can let our planes
there and shits on yeah god forbid we
would do something emerald war three
right in October 1944 US forces landed
an elite in the Philippines and it
became a real possibility to the
Japanese
that the war in their homeland was
possible I don't know who I'm rooting
for you're rooting for Dave in Chicago
okay
hero and 42 other students were informed
that they were going to help clean up
that mess
okay hero immediately went home to say
goodbye to his family not knowing the
next time he would see them he's got a
wife and kids
no no he's like his mom is dead
his mother gave him a dagger and as she
handed it to him she said if you were
taken captive use this to kill yourself
classic mom yeah she's really glad my
mom said this and let's go to college
mom yeah we got pictures why not the
first time I killed myself in a battle
situation was this is him you can go to
youtube and see this at all things
comedy and that's young hero there he is
nice hat
pretty serious about his uniform yeah
seriously no joke
well he's Japanese guy you didn't tell
me that yes I did he's Japanese he's
from Japan very clear hero ánotá they
took off in two bombers on December 17th
1944 this is the Japanese soldier
bombers yeah two bomber planes and they
landed at Clark Air Force Base and the
next day they went to Manila in the
Philippines yes there's a does Japan
control this part of the Philippines yes
right now well basically right now Japan
has this part of the Philippines but the
Americans are coming to take it and
they're sort of we're gonna [ __ ] take
it because we're [ __ ] America Russia
so when he gets to Manila he sees that
the American bombers were already
dropping leaflets he picked one up and
they read we are now in the South
Pacific
hoping to ring in a happy new year with
you and this made hero furious yeah yeah
cuz that's a that's way too nice yeah
well that's also I think a little
sarcastic but may it might have been for
the Islanders but for whatever reason he
reads this and he this is where his
hatred for the Americans really started
from a from a note from a leaflet drops
I mean let's let's reel it back a little
bit well the thing is that during the
war Roosevelt created a branch of the
army that was devoted to leaflet
dropping the leaflets were a way to
inform and warn enemy civilians but it
was also used as a way to
psychologically affect the enemy well it
sounds like it worked right away
goddamnit the the next war is gonna be
fought with post-its
I think tweets okay I think it is
actually now that I really think about
it right now
actually happen the Germans used
leaflets in World War two make the
Allied soldiers the Germans who the
Germans they're a big player why are you
just throwing stuff in at the last
second the Germans are in World War two
yeah okay yep big players huge players
okay kind of the you know the Pippin in
the musical Pippins I guess maybe just
don't assume I know stuff okay sure I
thought you were the okay okay nose so
the German leaflets were used to
psychologically affect soldiers one
depicted a passionate kiss between a man
and a woman and read farewell remember
her last kiss gee we were happy then
together you spent marvelous times
lounging on beaches dancing enjoying
parties galore great listening to the
tunes of your favorite bands wrong with
this well then if you're an American in
Germany you read that you're like Miss
Helen Oh what if you didn't miss Helen
Oh what if you're like now like I need
help I need a Hallett me an L things got
weird [ __ ] Helen also I'm starting to
realize I like dudes I'm around a bunch
of dudes right now dudes are pretty cool
so then they drop ones like a it'll
really complicate your mission don't
[ __ ] where you eat go home and meet a
nice guy that kid you played baseball
with he's gay now Gary I don't know it
is your new earth right while you
jumping into my fantasies I just want to
Holly I want to I want you to bang a guy
named Gary why I call him Gareth okay
fine that's that's when he corrects you
that's what I'm being paid for okay so
at the Air Force Base Hiro met with his
commanding officers among them was a
major Taniguchi hero is told to go to
Lubang island where he was promoted to
officer love Lubang by the way if you
guys never get there the pool you love
the bunks I can water the Sheraton is
ridiculous probably gonna we got an
actual picture of the well that's not
very good you brought up Adobe Photoshop
Express you got Adobe Photoshop
yeah this happens you want to open the
file and then and then say okay we're
keep using this is terrible whatever
it's it's basically
I can touch the screen touchscreen no
that's not working okay whatever the
point is there's a picture it's very
green yeah this is just a picture of
some guy yeah this is a good podcast
yeah so it is a picture of you let's see
if you can get a go in there because I
think that's very problem for the others
uh this is [ __ ] and so it is an
extremely precipitous island had high
mountains that were covered by jungle it
was full of rice farmers and when their
hero met with general Muto who simply
told them the war is quote not going
well at the moment that sesame one here
from a general not at all oh this is
okay so you could say oh that's nice
there's a guy in is that the soldier no
no it's just some dude I couldn't find
one of it just on its own well hero
looks pretty good it's very casual
that's not hero okay so it's a nice so
you could swim in the lagoon you got a
lot of Mounties in from war okay well
you know take a break during war catch
it catch it catch a swim I remember when
I was a kid my mother was driving me
somewhere and I we were talking about
war and I was like so during more you're
allowed to sort of say I need a minute
this is lunch or something I was like
six and she was like oh hey my son's an
idiot yeah so it's full of rice farmers
when there and he met the general he
said it's not going well you know he
then looked at Hiro and said that hero's
mission was going to be to blow up a
pier in an airfield
if the Americans were approaching got it
a job that proved daunting because
general Muto thought it was a better
tactic for the Japanese to try to kill
try to keep that area so on the morning
of January 3rd Oh
Hiro awoke to someone screaming
screaming enemy fleet sighted [ __ ] and
by February 28th 1945 it was starting to
hit luboc they started with bombs on
parachutes mortars guns and explosions
that rang out all over bombs on
parachute big play slow slow bomb yeah
and those those drive soldiers crazy too
because you see a common yeah and
there's tons of them yeah when they drop
them it's just like I mean it looks oh
you can't run around and catch soldiers
you get at a birthday party yeah yeah
yeah yeah but you can't run around catch
them in a car in it like in a cartoon
cuz there's too many it might be fun to
try you try it
I've given the world
a birthday party I can catch a bomb so
and then the Marines moved in they were
guarded by four tanks
needless to say hero side was outmatched
general Muto had a kidney infection and
he was laid out drinking coconut Minh
well [ __ ] kill yourself hero lamented
not wiring the pier and the airfield
seeing the level of screwed they were
hero urged the men to move into the
mountains where it was more covered by
trees but the morale was low and
everyone seemed pretty resigned to the
idea that they were just going to kill
themselves instead honorably while I'd
go into the mouth right well I mean but
that that's a great place for guerrilla
tactics but he's trying to get me out so
seeing their impending defeat hero not
allocated to soldiers private first
class cazuca and corporal schemata love
these and they ran schemata this who kid
schemata they're quite obscure mata
gazoo go no no no that's in the rider
cazuca will not perform if shimada's
name is first you know that she's okay
come on Shizuka you're combining them
now and that's not okay they've morphed
so those three all ran in the mountains
and they hid from the Americans Kazu
good chick ha ha
[Laughter]
so the coast became clear after a few
days and they started miniature how this
became clear well there weren't as many
I was sort of subsiding it sort of felt
like I probably hadn't gone well for the
people of Japan but they were still
afraid to return but they hid in the
mountains so they were able to survive
up there by making a low smoke fire sure
and making dishes to eat that were
basically banana or heavily featured
banana and the sounds of war really
stopped they were up there until like
August the sounds of war had stopped so
they women how many months is it they
came there in February so they're living
over there like six mayor up there for a
long time like just waiting waiting it
out there's still activity but they're
not coming into the mountains or when
they are coming in the mountains they're
hiding and they're sort of socially are
they getting along
socially things are tense things are
tense because you know they're very
afraid and they're eating only banana
mm-hmm you know so bananas good though
yeah not as every meal it's not in every
meal like they'd be rid of the banana
I have not this guy invented it in Japan
and the Philippines and the for the
story is oh yeah yeah yeah so it wasn't
until October 1945 when there was
contact with the enemy again but it was
nonviolent on the fifteenth hero saw a
leaflet on the ground that said in
Japanese quote the war ended on August
15th come down from the mountains by
that I'm saying the men all alignment
the men all looked at each other was
this true at the highest ranked hero
studied it and deemed it was a fraud
[ __ ] yeah it was a curious coincidence
though in that [ __ ] because it had all
the activity had stopped in August and
oddly enough Dave the war had indeed
ended no it was announced on August 15th
1945 and it was made official on
September 2nd well why you sending
sneaky notes look they're just not
sneaky not this is not someone likes you
in class well gonna send a note that
says hey invade down down in the valley
no no no no they're going there were
psychology I don't know if that's
reversed I would get a lot more people
killed probably if you think about it
you haven't thought about it and what
caused the war to end was you know
obviously that the u.s. dropped two
atomic bombs on Japan wasn't the [ __ ]
you talkin corrigible we're scams sorry
everyone I didn't know that yeah I think
America would ever do that mark is a
really good country yeah yeah yeah next
thing you know tell me is that Japan
tried to surrender first so heroes
training had not only taught him to
brainwash and confusing enemy but that
the enemy was trying to do the same to
him yeah yeah so he saw that in this
leaflet and instead of telling the men
to surrender he told them to use this
time to learn the terrain for when it
was time for the Japanese counter-attack
is the letter in English it's in
Japanese so they've already they were
two dudes yeah they already they all
read it and they're all looking at him
like so him Hammond Laverne & Shirley
they've already furniture Lee schemata
and cazuca same thing in Japan Japanese
emerge early yeah sure Mazel hot sand
pepper quarter right now yeah so I'm
telling it there was and it was a new
leaflet and
oh sorry on December 1945 a b-17 bomber
flew overhead and dropped leaflets all
over the area where the men were mainly
where they were this was a new leaflet
and the front had orders to surrender
from the great gym general Yamashita and
on the back was a map of the area where
the guys were circled in red and the
three men gathered and hero weighed in
do they know they're there it's pretty
clear that they know where they are
yeah so the three men gathered in her oh
wait in he believed this to also be
false yeah the men wondered why there
were a few issues Juro thought first on
their it said it would be they would be
hauled off to Japan thank you all seem
like a strong fucked-up war seemed
threatening the second red flag was that
it was called a quote direct Imperial
Order which Errol wasn't sure was a
thing the other men agreed and this was
also deemed fish yes hero also saw no
world in which the Japanese would wave
the white flag thank you or battle until
there was nothing left that's right but
that is the mentality that was instilled
yeah him in this training is like a
people are gonna be like trying to mess
with you all the time yeah and be this
war it might be a hundred years like
literal have you ever seen a Japanese
prank show
I wouldn't think they'd surrender this
it would be great to see this with a
little camera in the corner of people
reacting to his story yes I guess that's
your role let's get a camera on David oh
we already have one
so when 1946 rolled around there were
fewer and fewer gunshots one day however
they thought they heard an enemy
approaching they quickly saw it was a
fellow Japanese soldier forth private
class Dave sorry I'm doing dramatic but
this is nobody the video is less than
the audio so you should pay attention to
stuff I was doing good reactions yeah
but there's complicated stuff in here so
okay you know you should listen there
were fewer and fewer gunshots one day
however they thought they heard an enemy
approaching they quickly saw it was a
fellow Japanese soldier forth private
class a katsu kill him there were a few
other stragglers in the mountains of the
kill he was among him why did he kill
himself well you'll find the katsu if
you look at these four guys like the
cast of multiplicity a katsu would be
the fourth copy okay so he's like the
one who's like you stapling his shoe and
like all he's not great yeah he's not
great he's like Lenny and Squiggy no
yeah I really would not I'd rather not
frame painting a [ __ ] picture Oh God
so he joined them and they soon realized
that not only was a useless but he was
also hungry and now they were fun to
record why are we bringing in a hungry
guy how many bananas do we have there's
a lot of bananas okay bananas are pretty
ubiquitous so the food situation wasn't
easy was mainly banana they would slice
them with the skin on him wash them they
would then boil them in coconut milk it
was quote not good but what we ate most
of the time and then and now there their
name is officially the pasty [ __ ]
right yeah hey hey bananas we all hate
bananas send a lot of toilet paper
listen we're not gonna talk about how
much we hate bananas anymore okay we've
talked about how much we hate banana
I'll tell you what's not gonna make the
bananas taste better is talking about
how bad they are
yeah actually one thing though not a fan
of bad yeah no none of us are okay we
talked about how bad bananas are yes
conversation is ending okay this
conversation is ending right now and I
tell you about some innocent oh man the
bananas are great they're really [ __ ]
great I really want more bananas hey
queer more bananas yes we can because
they're [ __ ] great well that's all we
can have so they would cut them oh they
would also poach from farmers so they
would steal cows so wait there's [ __ ]
farmers cruisin around notnot not
cruising around they basically they're
like living in the mountains in this
jungle and if they go down at night down
into like where's our they could there's
a lot of farmers there's rice farmers
yeah and some of the farmers have
animals so they would go down there and
they would poach they would take rice
and then they would also poach cows from
the farmers how they would do it is they
were they would cut think they would
kill the cow then they would carry the
cow up they would disembowel the show it
would cook the meat for three days in a
row what the [ __ ] is happening eat it
then on day four no hold no you don't
just go on day four it was like hey
let's go down and kill a cow is anybody
else like that's a big [ __ ] animal
you remember the banana debate of
nineteen forty whatever [ __ ] fridge
or anything what are you do with a
[ __ ] cow I'm telling you there's a
plan okay so they cook the meat for
three days in a row I'm gonna get up the
hill then with the cow yeah it's a while
it's a bit of a hike
not great so they cut it they would cut
up in the cow they would cook the meat
they would cook and eat the meat for
three days in a row they basically do
that on a little grill then on the
fourth day they would put as much beef
in the pot as they could and they would
boil it and they would keep doing this
with the meat that remained every two
days to keep it from rotting oh no what
so every day they're realizing this
meats just rotting about they need their
pro team up with this [ __ ] I promise
heroes idea yeah re boiling meat well
that's how you keep it you know [ __ ]
reboil me I let this cow did not die in
vain
oh Jesus crying I think it's weirder to
eat it in an out burger this is [ __ ]
diarrhea City at this point are you
really worried about the bells so this
would last them for months if they won
one a day one cow would last the side of
it well one cow would like last one
person for months okay
they would also dry some for long term
snacking fun they were there also water
buffalos available but they didn't taste
good or there was horse meat which while
it was tender had an odor it's pretty
good though so the main ride that you
can ride the horse up the hill and then
kill oh my god it was actually the move
as a vegetarian so wait you're saying
for months how long have they been there
Oh at this point they've been there for
almost two years
okay the but the war ended in two years
ago the war ended in 1945 and now
they're in 1946 okay that's so they've
been here for a couple years hanging out
in the mountains yeah eating bananas and
cows yeah yeah and good cows healthy
cows and and so they were basically the
main dish was rice banana with cow meat
by April at the end of that year the
other men who were in the mountains had
surrendered so there were other like
soldier groups yeah there were other
groups and stuff but this this time
they'd all surrender because they're
giving up this comes home in [ __ ]
shame for being alive cowards right I
mean should kill yourself
yeah this caused more leaflets to drop
again surging the four remaining men to
pack it in cuz every time a dude rolls
in out of the force they're like holy
[ __ ] what is happening up there yeah and
how are you guys living there like we
just keep boiling cows for four months
and they're like what are you talking
basically they are like me tell them and
people like well how was your diarrhea
and they're really all the whole
mountain really bad full
it's a bad mountain so the leaflets had
notes telling the men to surrender quote
nobody is searching for you now but
Japanese come out and nobody cares
anymore please come out we don't we
really don't give a [ __ ] seriously we're
gonna start inventing electronics stop
eating Nana's and jerky but her oh let
me so great if they were eating on old
women Nana's no no no not in Hannah's Oh
more those cookies or both
Nana brought Nana's she's the mess of
God yeah so Hiro saw through this
leaflet that asked them to surrender he
believed that the surrendered soldiers
were being forced to do this by their
captors sure hero Hinata was getting
used to their BS no matter how specific
the note hero saw through it notes like
quote lieutenant doneita we have a stab
you establish contact with the search
party please come out we are at point x
combing this whole area please come to
this point we're tossed aside as enemy
tied up they know that means yes because
they know well first of all the other
guys and other groups of people who are
up there oh they come out and they're
like there's a [ __ ] there's a [ __ ]
as Luverne surely up there there's a
Lenny and Squiggy there's this these
guys keep biting their palms when hot
stuff happens it's a ten is a fonzie
everything writing a musical about your
cago whole crew up there and the
diarrhea is not good I tell you
something there's a reason they call
that place diary amount what well I did
first of all bananas but secondly have
you ever eaten three-month-old cow that
you've boiled 94 times McDonald's but
that didn't stop constantly flick
dropping and maybe it was affecting just
go up there and well that's okay relax
bro what are the dropping leaflets for
nine years because they're basically
going like hey guys it's over come you
would think I think they think that
these people are going to be like oh
okay for sure it's in Japanese it's got
like specific stuff from generals roll
up in a Japanese uniform and you're a
[ __ ] commander and go hey guys in
charge of this Jesus Christ what is
happening right now
so it was starting to affect the guys
the least are to affect me here
Shimada a kazoo and cazuca were all sort
of at this point one night over dinner a
katsu the bad hungry one asked
lieutenant don't you suppose the war's
truly ended he's gonna take his hat off
for that mom can we come Anna
Oh cuz he's in charge Pisa can we really
get [ __ ] serious here right now don't
you suppose the war bus do you not have
friends that way you don't want to go
back because you don't have any friends
and you want a [ __ ] little crew of
guys you can tell what to do
Nero was silent fools schemata broke the
silence I sort of have that I sort of
have that feeling too I feel like it has
schemata
schemata annoyed at this foolishness
hero said that there was a way to find
out at this point he was the highest
ranking member he would go down there
and check if he came back then they
would know the war was over which again
it was but if he didn't then they would
know it was still going on you keep
saying that like it is we don't know for
sure it is know for sure is for sure it
we don't know that for certain
yeah so as he got ready he grabbed two
grenades and I was always taking but
that was when cazuca stood up he said
that hérault didn't need to do that not
over what would clearly fake leaflets
this made the other two men back down
and agreed that they were wrong and that
the quad should stay up there and stay
the course this is a group of [ __ ]
idiots Kalina says can we dude they're
idiots
so they would all share one tent and
they moved around a lot to do enemy
wouldn't be able to trap how does this
story get worse every time you tell the
detail rainy season was hard because it
lasted from July until October what the
[ __ ] that's a lot of the time it's good
amount of the time they don't have new
clothes so they smell yeah and I imagine
their clothes to start following all
right dude they ran up there they just
ran up there with guns lady grabbing
that's all I had couple of grenades guns
and that was it they ran up they've just
to close we got to be in tatters at this
point yeah so the less they saw the
American soldiers the more they saw the
Lubang Islanders if they saw Islanders
they would shoot gun in the air to scare
the in in the air to scare the monster I
do that if they were spotted they would
shoot to kill and run away and change
locations by the way still a tradition
today if you visit there yeah a fun
tradition yeah yeah you can shoot it
only once I know it seems foolish
retrospect fine the amount of dead in
nineteen four
four years after the war had ended a
katsu had tried to escape three times
from the group to surrender
unsuccessfully that's what why don't you
just kill yourself though well I mean I
think at this point like because they're
not gonna be captured its if you're like
if if he goes down there and the war is
actually over it'll be okay like that's
what the leaflets are saying if you come
down it's cool they're not like
misleading them so you don't have to
kill yourself
the honorable suicide thing comes into
play like if you are going to be
captured a dead person is better than a
jailed first of all you don't tell me I
will tell you anything I'll tell you
suicide I will tell you what honorable
suicide is never talked to me like that
again
hero knew that if a katsu actually did
get away he would tell the enemy in the
war what they Belushi would tell the
enemy in the war that he believed he
would that was still happening
everything he knew this is a focaccia
gets away but that was better than
having him around he was that annoying
so a katsu ended up splitting you know
from the group yeah and he ended up
spending six months lost in the jungle
alone after he left he was not ready
it's down to the [ __ ] villager the
anyway these these are high these are
like you know these are tall mountains I
don't think it's a [ __ ] cows up there
they're grabbing their carrot look these
are guys who are fighting for survival
and they are they truly are like
machines like the a katsu the other
three guys are especially to Osaka katsu
so it got to wanders off so he's lost
for six months they eventually find him
and after it's full of bananas yeah just
so oh it's so full of it this guy
couldn't survive with the four like he
was annoying so by himself probably not
a good run yeah after he was found he
made contact via a note for the three
men near a campsite that read quote when
I surrendered the Philippine troops
greeted me as a friend
unquote it was indeed her it was indeed
in his handwriting so this was when this
was followed by more aerial activity
looking for the men but Hiro didn't buy
it no no a katsu was a prisoner being
forced to do this you're not they must
camp yeah he's right yeah he's right for
sure even though we're worried if four
years ago no okay the next day a new
tactic was used when they began hearing
messages blasted over loudspeakers that
said in Japanese yes sir
we dropped leaflets from an airplane you
have three days that is 72 hours in
which to surrender in the event that you
do not surrender in that time we will
probably have no alternative but to send
a task force after you well [ __ ]
bring it because I'm up here I'm I got
[ __ ] cows and bananas and I can go
all [ __ ] year so every part of the
loudspeaker did seem legit but hero
thought that the use of 72 hours was odd
Jesus Christ it sounded like a
translation to him so he's so was he
always a paranoid lunatic no that I
don't think I think they instilled this
in the army
I think they really did I think they
were in the army they were like you no
matter what yes you mislead and they're
gonna do the same what you know
something to that effect
they basically trained lunatics to go in
the mountains well they weren't supposed
to go in the mountains but we have
trained lunatics in the mountains now so
he thought it sounded like a translation
that was not how a Japanese person would
have phrased that right he said he was
impressed by the accent though whoever
did it had done their homework but if
anything taro this was evidence that the
war was indeed still going on a little
bit like reading an American sushi menu
or being honest it seemed desperate to
him yeah Shema do a schemata and cazuca
agreed hero is still hung up on the idea
that if the war had ended someone would
have been sent to discharge them thank
you beyond that Japan would never
surrender the mission was too important
nothing could change that Japan wouldn't
surrender until everyone was dead he
really believed that well sure enough
after 72 hours there was a surge of
Philippines search parties looking for
the men all right they would rotate
between hiding and shooting to scare to
scare them to what they they thought
these search parties were also fake they
also had an advantage of living in the
mountains for years and at this point
knew the mountains better than even the
Islanders of course they did yeah it's
for their [ __ ] island now at this
point I think the Islanders should leave
I got cows up there bro that anybody who
can carry a cow to the top of a mountain
owns the mountain this is like when a
party like a group of cool people go to
do cocaine are you in the cocaine room
or in the lame-ass party room why are
they the cool people though sorry what
did I say cool people yeah it seems like
black people lame people let's move on
in February of 1952 seven years after
the war had ended February 1952 seven
more
a Philippine Air Force plane flew abrupt
above them and shouted their names over
loudspeaker dropping leave their own
their own names full name shall name I
mean at some point you got a big man
this war is super focused it's just a
really focused war yeah they're really
into us I think we're important kills
the nape and maybe perhaps just tell me
just throw this out guys
maybe this war is actually about bananas
and cows and maybe we're [ __ ] winning
you ever think about that we got eight
more bananas and cow so there were a few
different leaflets that were dropped on
that day this is when the loudspeakers
shouting their names on repeat one of
them appeared to be a letter from Hiro's
brother Toshio in it he said that the
war had ended and that the family missed
him and that he could leave cazuca and
schemata also had letters from their
families I assume these letters a little
more detailed than what you're saying
well there's a lot of them but yeah but
no essentially it's like yeah it's like
his brothers I mean essentially it's
like you have you have it's me your very
favorite toy was this in your kid
blabbity blah it's no it's not that
specific I don't think our mom was
pretty hot oh that's a weird thing to
say in a letter right now but my god I
hope they don't only give me one piece
[ __ ] I just talked to them I can only
use this one alright look mom was kind
of hot yeah anyway you can leave don't
you miss us how high do you think mom
was Oh check a box come back you gotta
talk about MA right
dibs I got here a long time man
so Hiro studied his and he shook his
head and he said that the Yankees had
really outdone themselves this times off
isn't it the other men who had been up
there long enough listening to Hiro also
found issues they scrutinized everything
and hérault took real issue with
shimada's family picked the most the
letter had called the picture of ones of
their quote immediate family but in the
pic there was a relative who was not
immediate family what the [ __ ] just
family who's this guy he's like an uncle
or something it's just some [ __ ]
random and that was it
the whole thing was called yeah of
course more fake news cuz they put a
[ __ ] fake guy in a family what kind
Anakin's are they up to
I know who my family is that guy's not
my family get me more boiled cow sir
it's it's only banana time what we're
out of go I thought this is cow day
we couldn't find a cow so we're gonna
have to do but here's what we're gonna
do okay we're gonna do what we did a
couple weeks ago remember we said it was
good when we pretended we were eating
chicken and it was the banana okay we're
gonna do that again
so let's make the chicken noises and
let's just eat the amendment so then
about a month later more loudspeaker
announcements a month later yeah they
helped they they were a month later
they're like these guys are these guys
are they're not buying the family [ __ ] I
knew we should have put that fake achill
Jesse in there it's cuz Toshio wrote
that thing about his mother she's pretty
hot though she is hot so when they take
a look at the setup they found a
Japanese newspaper had been left for
them it was the first newspaper that
they had seen in seven years nobody
thought to [ __ ] do this right off the
bat now it's suspicious in there was an
article about lieutenant colonel
nobuhiko Jimbo sounds a little weird who
had negotiated peace between the nations
and helped end the war that article was
circled in red the men studied it they
looked a hero who called the newspaper
real but he called the article candy
poison boom it looked good but was
deadly so real paper fake article thank
you nice truck I didn't want to say it
but that was thanks to us that is
[ __ ] clear like no it's clearly fake
news big news in 1953 schemata was shot
in the leg while trying to scare some
fishermen we've all been there well
Jesus crying why is he scaring fishermen
but now what now would war we [ __ ]
fighting oh he's just scaring random
fishermen well I think it's in I first
of all he might have just been like out
walking around like if I doesn't look
very good yeah no they look like they're
like yeah but so he got shot and leg and
immediately they got him back and hero
made a tourniquet and they got him out
no the wound was bad though since they
had no medicine hero had to make us
went for his leg her Oh would then suck
the blood out from around the wound and
cover it with cow fat every day this
went on for 40 days hey just everybody
knows go ahead kill me yeah go ahead and
wrap it up I'm good I'm good that's what
you like like give me banana to Dada
cram of banana in my eye just do
something bad right now
because the if I'm ever in a mountain
for seven years and then I get shot you
start putting calf out fat on me [ __ ]
it's not working out I was down there
giving you like wound alingas that part
I like okay interesting now somehow
schemata turned out he's gonna be okay
however that was physically something
had changed in him yeah I got shot by
the house sherman he talked about his
family more he pondered if his
grandfather was dead or if his eldest
daughter was dating this is me also when
he left his wife is pregnant and he's
like was it a boy or girl schemata was
fixated on the leaflets as well he would
talk to himself a lot and reply with a
oh nothing when asked what he'd yeah
yeah that you should dude [ __ ]
kicking it in a banana forest that's
classic stuff so he'd say oh nothing
when they were like what was gonna like
nothing so then one day he rose snuck up
behind him to hear what he was saying
and when he snuck up on them just to
hear him he snuck up on a guy to hear
I'm talking to himself that's where
we're at now so he sneaks in the guy and
schemata is looking at a picture his
family and he's muttering ten years ten
whole years and it had been ten years
that's a long [ __ ] time on may 7th
1954 schemata was in some shade close
their tent when an Islander man was
making some noise kill him Hiro spotted
and fired two shots at him yeah the man
screamed and retreated but schemata
stood up with his gun pointing to
nowhere in particular he was spooked
heroic azúcar could only watch in horror
when suddenly a bullet shot Shimada in
the head he was dead instantly is he
okay he's dead no he got shot in that
dead instantly
is he okay though he's not gonna make it
what if her trail runs over it's like
sucking on it get the cow fat get the
cow fat but the truth is had he gone
home it probably wouldn't be great
either because his wife had already
married his younger brother oh [ __ ] no
what's her [ __ ] problem she was sick
of this guy I don't marry the brother
jesus [ __ ] christ like him it's good
stuff it's like when you replace a cat
with a cat
it looks like an holy [ __ ] that's not
what like when you're the president that
means she was always into the brother
let's be [ __ ] honest before he went
off to a younger hotter
give me gimme gimme he's no way she
wasn't [ __ ] in during the [ __ ] war
or before the first before I don't think
that's fair [ __ ] I think when your
husband is you already got read for his
brother you don't hear anything
your brother's there he's comforting you
you know it gets laid all of a sudden
you know the the restrictions that were
put on you before aren't there because
you needed someone to console you and
here you are just the two kids and the
night wondering what's going on and
someone brings out some wine well you
have a little bit of that and next thing
you know it's later than it should be
you should go home but it's cold you
don't want to and he doesn't want you to
either that's when someone comes up and
a back massage turns into a sweet little
neck kiss then you know where net kiss
goes right to the bedroom well after
that you've already sinned what's the
point of not having another morning soon
well then you can't get him out of your
goddamn head week's go by massages sex
it's nonstop but you shouldn't you
shouldn't you shouldn't after you you
should I'll tell you what huh oh sorry
sorry sorry sorry
should I go right no no stay I mean go
go and then come back in like ten
minutes
I hope they [ __ ] and I hope every night
they [ __ ] wake up and they smell
bananas and they don't know what's
happening well I know what's happening
that's the [ __ ] ghost of schemata no
that's unfair so then there's two hero
and cazuca now the death of Shimada we
know I thought there were no third guy
remember katsu went off for six months
alone but that he came back he'd know
you come on no let's note him whatever
cam here's like hey guys it's pretty
cool hey guys it's all good yeah yeah so
he so the death of schemata was reported
and caused the people of Japan to
protest wanting the other two soldiers
back yeah yeah yeah so now like people
know that that hero and cazuca are alive
it's 40 and 55 and people are like that
we got a couple of bros up there in the
mountains so this result first of all
second of all we're losing a lot of cows
that's true - PETA was like we also have
a protest so was an Islander guy was a
some some Filipino town guys shot and
these attacks are like happening you
know fairly regularly but the ship but
the schemata one yeah there's
confirmation that there are two other
guys that it's her no and I assume the
the Filipino villagers whatever do not
are not a joint there's no crazy just
the mountains yeah they're also taking
their food and taking their food still
think an active war is going on in every
Philippine every Islander they would
call him the Liu bang Islanders every
one of them they would just assume was
an enemy so if they ran off they weren't
an enemy but if they were shooting back
then that was viewed as you know a
threat and that was enough to shoot up I
still do that if I go on vacation
as an American I view you're allowed to
have you anybody how long until he's
turning we're their international gun
permits as an enemy we want
international gun permits so if you if
you have a hotel you're in your mind
even though I'm staying there your
bartenders none of me
the belt the bellboys enemy it's time to
the flight with what no good lord all
right we're moving on
so after this sort of results in a
national movement in Japan to go get
these guys and the result of that was
that what they did instead was didn't
they went and collected bones of dead
soldiers from World War two we can you
guessed it more leaflets wait what what
do you mean they will be like on a bone
hunt people they go on a bone hunt yeah
it's fine what the [ __ ] that's fun
come on Japan get your [ __ ] together so
it within ten days an Air Force plane
dropped leaflets saying hero cazuca the
war has ended and then there was more
search parties and the search party
could not find them because they were so
good at covering their tracks yeah one
day on a walk
hero spotted a Japanese flag that had
his the names of his family members on
it it's a [ __ ] warning as far as I'm
concern is that his brother's wife's
signature and her name was spelled why
asue looked like the e was left out but
her Oh didn't think this was a fake
message from the Americans he thought
this was a message
from Japan to him through the Americans
sure the Americans dropped it but that
was Japanese trickery with all these
leaflets that came from America the
Japanese were probably worried that her
row may give in so they probably gave
the US the flag to drop it saying it
will help them help them get him to give
up but they used the subtle misspelling
in the signature as a way to signal that
a counter-attack would happen Hiroto
cazuca his theory and cazuca obviously
totally agreed yeah makes sense makes
total sense easy to expect this point
none of this doesn't not make sense it's
all coming together so they believe that
the Japanese counter-attack is days away
[ __ ] yes they did enjoy the leaflets
though because it was good to see their
families sometimes the work of the
Americans was so sloppy for instance one
leaflet had a picture of Kazuki's family
standing in front of a house that wasn't
theirs quote how do you expect me to
believe this because you can ask why
would my family be standing in front of
a new house that doesn't belong to us
holy [ __ ] this is exactly so the [ __ ]
propaganda here is so sloppy is deep you
get worst of all they're coming up with
the wrong people that don't belong in
the family now it's fake [ __ ] houses
fake news this is a [ __ ] [ __ ] show
the leaflets were also printed on cheap
paper which meant to the pair that they
were probably being dropped on mass
which in turn meant the Japanese had
armies all over the Philippines so they
think that like very specific leaflets
are being dropped in specific areas yes
yes oh that all makes sense
years went by and routines solidified no
when you say years
I mean worried about you know were
somewhere in I mean we're about we're
about 10 to 12 years now it's about 12
years now so yeah usually wouldn't you
just go talk to someone they had a few
places wouldn't you just roll into the
village and be like hey Mike I ask you a
question bro know that dude then when
they go to the village they were like
we're gonna take hostages if we need to
so they had a few places where they
would settle they made huts and they
would break them down and stash the
pieces they could rebuild them when they
returned yeah yeah for safety they moved
around a lot and never stayed in a spot
more than three nights when it wasn't
raining during the rainy season they
made a bamboo hut and they stayed inside
it for longer stretches and it was lined
with coconut leaves inside of it they
made a rock stove to cook
I my dad and I made a rock stove during
Vietnam when we were trapped on an
island does your picture not work
yeah it works so there's a rock stove so
this is these are actually hero's
drawings so they would do stuff like
that's pretty good rock stone yeah and a
good drawing of it but yeah it was you
so they're cooking up there they're
basically have they're having a good
time as far as I'm concerned yeah it's a
great place right go right underneath
this so underneath the stove it said we
shot a cow we shot a cow yeah Edda
bragging yeah
the conditions were brutal there were
five types of ants on the mountain that
had stingers the stings would swell up
immediately Hiro called the island one
big anthill once a row got stung on his
eardrum and he couldn't hear out of his
ear for a week okay so let me just say
this right now I'm out I'm out after two
days I'm out I'm sorry I was telling you
you never brought up ants how do you not
[ __ ] start with ants it was oh by the
way there are ants like that's how you
tell his story it wasn't uncommon to be
attacked by a swarm of bees or to find a
centipede or a scorpion where you slept
rats were around nine inches long this
is The Devil's Dominion and the snakes
were as wide as a thigh Adri was hard
because clothes would not only Hardy was
hard but literally rot like you were
talking about the trousers would rot in
the knees the seat the bottoms in the
crotch which i think is everywhere so
they would make a needle out of wire and
they would use some thread from the tent
and a piece of canvas from the tent to
patch up their clothes but there was no
soap so sometimes they would just boil
their clothes what in the [ __ ] they're
good and then the ants I don't care
about the clothes he gets there in the
air Jim can you hear [ __ ] ants all
over every singing you every why just
kill yourself or surrender no dudes not
honorable
ants now they certainly kept up their
guerrilla tactics they would carry out
what they called beacon fire raids where
they would leave the jungle Mountains to
burn rice fields of the farmers every
October [ __ ] them since that was the
beginning of the dry season it was
exceptionally problematic yes
so while carrying out the rage they
would sometimes steal canned goods
coffee cigarettes sometimes they would
also try to collect intelligence from
the Iowans yeah this would sometimes
result in direct conflict which they
would handle with guns threatening the
lives of not only the farmers but the
farmers families they killed when they
felt that they were threatened and that
they had to and they felt no guilt
because to them this was
war water was easy because all of the
streams were there but they always
boiled the water because there was
always some animal pissing in at
upstream
classic [ __ ] Philippines every night
hero took notes on the day's events and
sightings thinking it would be helpful
for the Japanese counter-attack they
would cut each other's hair with
makeshift scissors on the 28th of every
month hair pals they would keep an eye
on their urine to see if they need if
they needed more rest or we dehydrate or
okay so we do that when we're on tour
absolutely yeah they would examine each
other's stool to see how their health
was stupa its up I mean there are there
are limits of friendship you know what I
mean like there's a there's a there's a
there's a place in a friendship where
you go we don't have to do that's very
specific as to what you want to see I
don't wanna I'm not no matter what
happens between us I'm never gonna look
at your [ __ ] and be like you didn't
either are you alright horse no no man
that was in the spring of 1958 almost 13
years after the war it ended a large
search party was Forbes price with more
of their families and a small army now
his family's coming out they went all
over the mountains and simply kept
repeating on a loudspeaker
lieutenant inada private first class
cazuca we have come from Japan to look
for you please talk with us and come
back to Japan with us they played the
Japanese national anthem and Japanese
folk songs they went all over the island
cute the Americans seem to be starting
another one of their fake rescue
operations hero said cazuca agreed what
a nuisance
let's move somewhere where it's quiet
I'm in somewhat of a good time well the
truth is the bond between these two was
the strongest they've got a friendship
going on they were brothers a couple of
bros they probably didn't make each
other laugh and stuff - I mean sure
you've heard well they've heard heroes
the same joke a lot but I don't think
they were even making each other laugh
but their lives are literally like we
should go over there and try to for
Jenny be like yeah forging over there
would be good yeah and I was like
everyday yeah but don't you ever want
just a really simple basic life yeah but
I would love to have variety
I mean without ants without an ya see
remember remember Nance but but but
there's a piece to the simplicity of
their life yeah I don't know how people
talking my life without Twitter yeah but
I think you can I think I think there's
a middle ground and it doesn't have ants
in it
so after a while they snuck out to get
another peek of what the search party
was doing and two heroes surprise he
heard his brother Toshio over the lads
I can't believe they have him as
prisoner he said he he said hero come
out this is your brother Toshio this is
our last day here please come out when
we could see you Hiro was curious and
after all was his brothers voice but he
was sure it was a recording of some kind
so he's not closer to get a look
he couldn't get close enough to see the
man's face but he was sure that it was
the build of his brother and the voice
was identical that's really something he
said they found a prisoner who looks at
a distance like my brother and he's
learned to into he's learning to imitate
my brother's voice perfect Jesus Christ
I mean the weird thing is is that the
war is now all about him that's how
[ __ ] Impa that's how important the
work he's doing is yeah that's how
important
well his mission is to eat all the
bananas and lose hearing that's right
close to completing it mission is almost
to come to get as much antvenom in you
as possible so that his brother sang
heroes tokyo high school alma mater and
towards the end my voice began to crack
and get emotional and go off tune hiro
laughed to himself he knew this hack
would show his true colors yes so the
search party left behind a stack of
newspapers and magazines like two feet
tall like playboy like now spin us out
yet now probably even then no no playboy
but so there's got to be like you know
like in mash like the the nude women
playing tennis and stuff now this is
jerk-off stuff right now again I'm being
really more like why would you leave
anything in the forest it wasn't nude
for guys did you well this is actually
this evolves into forest porn charlie
yeah clearly they were fake because on
the papers a lot of them talked about
life in Japan after the war and again
there was no way the war was over if the
war was over there wouldn't even be
papers thank you so one of the ads in
the paper called was for a book called
general Yamashita the man the ad read
quote why was it that Yamashita who was
considered the greatest Japanese general
did not succeed in the war here is the
life story of the fiery militarist a
story that might be entitled the tragic
general when heroic azúcar saw that they
laughed
Yamashita was the best general ever boy
the americans must be
afraid of him to go that far with a fake
admin right this is really shitty
writing yeah it's not good it's [ __ ]
bad so this game goes on for a while
search parties begging for them to come
out here own cazuca scoffing laying low
they almost welcome the rainy season
because they'd be left alone thank you
and that basically happened and banana
season and but hand which is year-round
and banana hammock season is summer
months that basically happened because
in 1959 they were finally declared dead
ah so they're officially declared dead
[ __ ] by the Japanese cover
they're like okay [ __ ] it [ __ ] guys [ __ ]
these here's the headline can you print
this up [ __ ] those guys [ __ ] those guys
okay and then just a story will be
they're [ __ ] dead
[ __ ] them we don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] them
they're not our [ __ ] problem how much
how much [ __ ] papers we wasted how
much paper have we wasted someone tell
me can you make tell me it's a lot of
[ __ ] paper oh that's a lot of [ __ ]
paper gestures oh so they're dead sighs
the dead to me the dead to you great
we'll run that tonight sir so knowing
wasn't true like the Philippine like the
Islanders knew obviously they were still
alive because they had been killing them
yeah yeah which is a dead giveaway
that's a super to tell and knowing it
wasn't true this made the Japanese
public call for their finding more than
ever signs went around Japan oh my god
it's a stretch protests and petitions
geez but it was all ignored by the
Japanese government cuz they're dead six
years later on New Year's Eve 1965 six
year twenty years after the war five
after the war had ended 20 years at
forty five now they got a big score it's
close they got a big score when they
stole the radio oh no they're 40 because
they went over there 20 he's a little
older I think yeah I think after the
training he's a little older so they got
a score though after 20 years dude they
get a prize would you relax they got a
Toshiba
eight transit er transistor radio went
they went into the village and they got
a [ __ ] radio yeah like they would do
like little thing you know when a farmer
would leave or something they'd maybe
sneak into a pad again they take some
cigarettes some of the other they forgot
a battery they got a radio there got a
bunch of batteries they stole and it
it was New Year's Eve so they went back
up and they listened to the New Year's
show from Japan yeah now the radio gave
them in their first world update since
the fake news of 1959 that they received
however they had to play it low they did
not want to believe anything they heard
as far as far as the military or the war
so anything they heard about military or
the war that anything that pertained to
that they believed to be something that
the Americans had edited so any
mentioning of the war was BS cazuca
looked at hero and said when you think
about it the Americans are really good
at this aren't they yes hero said they
had to take out anything they don't want
us to hear and rebroadcast that in
almost no time I take my hat off to them
it must be very tricky work by 1968 23
years after the war had ended hero and
cazuca weren't getting along famously
anymore I mean at some point just being
with another dude in the mountains with
some what happened no I'm rotting roni
clothes and ants and and snakes
relationship can I see your stool I
don't want to show it I don't want to
look at your stool today oh my look at
my chit none of us are doctors so they
would have petty arguments and that
sometimes ended in rock fights but
that's like classic dude yeah Rock
fights for sure
on October 18 1972 27 years after the
war had ended they went out for their
annual beacon fire rates this year was a
little different because the rainy
season had gone longer than usual so by
the time they got to the farms that
month's harvest was near done which left
them fewer options as to when they could
light the fires they decided that they
would go after the farmers the next day
following afternoon they'd come down and
shoot their guns in the air with farmers
scatter as there's aught to do and then
cazuca lights a fire they're lighting
the rice on fire
hiro stole some left behind coffee and
some cigarettes and they're close to
getting away when one more rice pile was
just calling Kazuki's name sure so he
runs back to light it but that's when
the cops arrive [ __ ] so then gunshots
ring out and the two of them dive down
into different areas and start hiding
but Hiro is they don't the fire's
everything on fire and then I think in
the field they ran they kind of ran up
into the mountains a little bit like
they coverage gets better the further up
you go but they're starting to get in
there so they're trying to get into the
shrubs and because you had been hitting
the
[ __ ] so hero shoots at the man trying to
buy them a minute but then cazuca was
hit again but this time in the chest he
fell blood was coming out of his mouth
and Hiro watched his eyes white and he
was gone dead
Hiro ran off bowing revenge [ __ ] yeah
he's gonna get [ __ ] revenge so now we
rode Ben spot so even if the war is over
guess what yeah it's back on
yeah that's kind of what's happening
yeah well now for a new war now it's
funny man yeah like we call this World
War 3 now it's not still well good point
let's call it two point one all right
back on let's say World War two back on
let's pitch after so he rode been
spotted which ended the debate in Japan
over whether he was alive or dead so the
outcry swells and this makes his legend
grow and ideas on how to get him out
range from having the Emperor record a
message saying the war was over 200 to
having a fake army of Japanese soldiers
return to make him think to come back so
that's what you well this is yeah this
is also what they did to me after
Vietnam I stayed in that YMCA for a good
23 years and they eventually have no the
Emperor came by the Africa of the Y yeah
you have to leave these are rented rooms
you can boy it smells like banana and
here's this not a Christian organization
I think that's my question for you sir a
lot of stool I've been growing bananas
oh my god this is like the Martian a
second question am i okay
no get Apple can you check my stool
absolutely not and I saw some it's not
good so but in the end they landed with
this plan search parties and leaflets
good because that's that has worked so
far
a not astounding thing is gonna get out
of this it's [ __ ] [ __ ] written on
paper
anat asan wherever you are come out we
can guarantee your safety or we had a
report that you had shown up here and we
think you are somewhere where you can
hear this speaker or not a son if you
don't believe we are Japanese load up
your infantry rifle before you come out
blast it on loudspeaker ooh the Rockford
Files are almost on here
laughter to him we're about to get into
Hawaii five-o he wasn't gonna fall for
this so they called off the search party
but they again left newspapers and
magazines behind and this time there was
a full-page story on cazuca hero wanted
to believe them but they made it so hard
because in the paper they said that
cazuca had a five cent and a 10 cent
piece in his pocket but hero knew that
he had it in his waistband not in his
pocket so sadly well dude and more be
he's trying to buy the little things the
subtleties but not clearly clearly that
is a clear message that is obviously a
message yeah family from his family also
described ever are the spiders and the
insider who knows someone be God so
there's this one person who's fast
everybody's fascinated by the story but
there's one guy named norio Suzuki he's
a college dropout who was well-traveled
and he was prone to taking trips around
the world and for his next trip he said
he wanted to see quote lieutenant inada
a panda and the abominable snowman in
that order [ __ ] yes that order we
finally have a [ __ ] hero who's gonna
track down here yeah okay well done by
February 1973 28 years after the war had
ended the loudspeaker and leaflet
campaign continued this time involving
people hero went to middle school with
pleading for him to come back hero felt
sorrier although all these people who
didn't know they were being taken
advantage of right you know what
everyone is getting [ __ ] it's a gang
No yeah I hope they were their uniform
yeah I'd be weird weird and now we want
you guys to wear uniforms still sorry
guys it's Network justice on this
network wants you to wear them it's so
weird if they were if there were a bunch
of Japanese guys they're doing a World
War Two reenactment oh god he's like
finally here we go
so it seemed like his huts and his
little camp sites were also known as
well because friends left assigned
school uniform in one his brother left a
note in one but the saddest one of all
was a poem from his father that he left
in one of the huts that read simply
quote not even an echo responds to my
call in the summary Mountains Jesus dad
drops a hammer
that holy [ __ ] he comes with the [ __ ]
echo again brutal that knows how to
[ __ ] get you in the gut man every
time so now that you've been leaving
magazines and newspapers like in the
huts where they know he's staying so
it's like he has a subscription so he
replies you actually replies to his
father's note says he's okay and then
baozi is never gonna go back to that
area again so February 19th 1974 he
notices this mosquito net at a camp and
Hiro had no choice but to attack so he
turns the safety off his gun and he
approaches a man by the river he called
out to him and the man is totally
freaked out whatever reason not sure why
the man was none other than norio Suzuki
and he can although cutting his hair on
the 28th I don't at this point I don't
know I mean now that because I don't
know I feel like there's certain rituals
in him letting go once my bro's dead his
hair it nice hair still he's still
keeping it tight tight for sure to keep
it tighter absolutely so he calls to
this guy and he's stealing clothes from
the village right so he's close yeah and
he's dressed ish ish yeah like I mean as
far as you can like he doesn't look that
crazy
he's Shay's not he is he is shaving yes
but he is also not like he's not wearing
whatever clothes he's still in his army
uniform like so he's just repairing his
uniform he's using clothes that he takes
he's using that like fabrics like an
AIDS quilt so he she's got that vibe
okay yeah he looks like something you'd
see at the goodwill a bit oh absolutely
not it's like when did this 70s when
they just had a clothes made out of a
bunch of different patches what about
all these years yeah so he calls out to
him the guys freaked out and all he
could say was I'm Japanese I'm Japanese
and he's shaking so hero isn't sure what
to make of him I'm a tourist he said
does this guy have a panda with him or
or no no no the order is he's gonna find
him then the Panda then by the way panda
start with Panda I start with Panda for
sure so he said I he couldn't believe he
said are you or not a son and Hiro
admitted that he was
Tsuzuki couldn't believe it he said I
know you've had a long hard time but the
war's over won't you come back to Japan
with me the Emperor and the people of
Japan are worried about you Hiro told
them that quote the war is not over for
me you wouldn't
yeah if you want me to go back to Japan
bring me my orders
there must be proper orders that reminds
me of that wrestling clip where you know
the guys like they've just seen the clip
where the guys like in the stands and
he's like talking to pro wrestlers and
he's like you know 38 and he's just like
look it's still real to me damn you oh
it's just worthwhile that's pretty great
so that's what he and he wants orders
that makes sense he wants orders he not
only wants yeah it does like he wants
like official he's been he was told
early you do not quit so he orders yeah
so Suzuki offers him a cigarette and
some J's right all Rambo wanted so and I
assume this is based on Rambo this is
not based on Rambo but good guess again
I think this your second time guessing
right well I work in her first time so
he offers him a cigarette and gin hero
takes the smoke but he passes on the gin
why because hero is still not sure how
legitimate this guy was he still thought
there was a very good chance he was
going to have to kill him yeah so hero
did take some beans that he ate straight
from the tin and he said that it was it
felt like quote it was the first time in
30 years I was eating something fit for
human being I just went right through
so Suzuki kept wanting to know how we
could actually get hero back but he was
consistent I said make major Taniguchi
is my immediate superior until I won't
give in until I have my direct orders
from him hero he's dead mmm-hmm yes it's
I hate to I hate to call back one of our
happiest references but then it's
weekend at major taniguchi's it's go
time before reanimation so hero is
beginning to actually trust and like
Suzuki Suzuki the main reason he thought
he was away in it who's this ugly guy
nice nice day it's fun to be in the it's
fun to be in the passenger seat isn't it
so the main reason why I started
trusting was because he was wearing
sandals with socks which he had never
seen on an Islander oh [ __ ] no so by the
end of the night they're heading out
when everybody near a beach doesn't do
that that's like tourist [ __ ] yeah so by
the end of the night he even lets
Suzuki take some pictures of him one
would the two of them together and with
that they part ways and Suzuki left him
with quote I'll come back for you as
soon as I can the press will make a huge
story out
this you won't believe it so no any any
sort of technological advancement that
comes doesn't mean anything because time
is passing so he just thinks yeah
everything's different so anything
that's different he just wraps into his
little he time what is time
so this is the point of the pictures
they took of Hiro and Suzuki oh my God
look at those ooh keys like this dude so
he's essentially like they look [ __ ]
great yeah so he's essentially Suzuki is
just like this dude it's amazing and
he's just like finds him and I was like
can I take a pic how is this not a like
a show like this should be on longer
than mash so they agreed that they would
leave a mere Oh agreed that to
communicate they would leave messages in
this box because of the search parties
there were all these little weird note
boxes that have been set up sure to try
and communicate so they agreed a
specific box they would communicate
through and Suzuki was not lying about
the press he was gonna get either he
made his way directly to the Japanese
Embassy in Manila and showed the proof
within a day the pictures were on the
front page of all Japanese newspapers
the government got Taniguchi yeah cuz
it's literally like he [ __ ] found
Bigfoot totally totally
it really is people like oh [ __ ] yeah so
the government got Taniguchi and with
Tsuzuki and then they also got Hiro a
notas brother Toshio and they all sent
them back to Lubang after two weeks who
wrote check the box and there were items
in it one was one of the pictures of
Hiro and it was the first time he had
seen his face in 30 years and he thought
to himself that he looked like one of
his uncle's oh [ __ ] this is when stuff
starts to hit you at a certain age like
oh my god it looked like my uncle so
area that old rascal it's him after the
pictures but so and then there's a note
with the pictures there's a note that
says from Tsuzuki that says quote I've
come back for you just as I promised
along with that there were two army
orders one which was required to be
given in person by Taniguchi which is
exactly what hero wanted so hero is now
fairly confident that this was all real
but he still wouldn't let his guard down
as you walk to the rendezvous point he
thought to himself I'm not gonna let
thirty years of hard work go down the
drain I get ready with a [ __ ] gun
ready right here oh yeah Arenado right
[ __ ] and
yes by shooting some [ __ ] up
and come out of the jungle let the man
know like who like Rambo shut up Dave so
he readies his rifle and moves towards a
tent kill him and he first sees Tsuzuki
and he says ooh key immediately yells
out it Sanada made a ton of Gucci it
Sanada and Hiro approaches and sure
enough its major tonic Gucci holy [ __ ]
they like stand there they're having
this moment and then Taniguchi you know
starts reading these orders and the
orders say that there are absolutely no
more orders for him to carry out yeah
and he's relieved by him and these are
official dismiss dismissal papers yeah
so his service was over he was 52 years
old
Hiro's backpack became heavier than a
bottle but that's a lot of back pay a
lot of by the way there's a [ __ ]
shitload of back pay so he said his
backpack feels heavier than ever
yeah he's silent and then he just looks
and he gets angry he wanted to know what
he had been doing how could the Japanese
be so sloppy why did we give up
he's livid and then he called [ __ ]
legit questions mom's down they spend
the night and the idea is the next day
he was going to get a pardon from the
from the President of the Philippines
because he had already committed a lot
of crimes well I know they're crimes of
your war that's fair but there was one
rule he couldn't clean up too much they
wanted him to look like he had been worn
down as a prisoner for a little bit so
he could however sneak on the fresh
undies that taniguchi's wife gave him to
pass along okay so just tell you
something right now
you can be out in the mountains for
[ __ ] 30 years but you get a [ __ ]
fresh pair of a new if they're Mac
weldings you got another 30 years
it's no joke okay so the worst brought
to you by Mac Wells so later hero meets
with President Marcos says plan I've
seen the underwear I know you're not
gonna see his underwear he meets with
President Marcos his plan and her Oh
presents him with a sword in an act of
honorable surrender so that's that's no
it's no [ __ ] question is that Marcos
gets killed Dave after this Dave that's
not that's not for now and he got a full
pardon
it's estimated that he killed 100 men in
his time there [ __ ] yes guys our t is
Rama he's a mass murder
he said it was more like 52 he's a mass
murderer no I mean he's a mass war he's
a [ __ ] psycho in the mountain he's a
gorilla in the mist
so uh within an hour he's on a
helicopter he's headed back to Japan so
Hiro inada arrived in Japan to great
fanfare see where it's he like [ __ ] I
killed 50 people for no real he feels no
guilt he's a [ __ ] lunatic look he
feels no guilt okay Hiro not arrives in
Japan to great fanfare he was greeted
like a Beatle he was swarmed by the
press and photographers constantly
that's a lot I sign when I'm feeling
living with ants and bananas for 30
years and all of a sudden people are
talking it's a lot you might end up back
there like I miss my amp I might hear
Jeff my man look like my uncle he can't
even sleep without getting bitten by
ants right now yeah no you can we get an
bed in here like like it's just like a
water bed with ants in them so you can
just sort of feel them but they don't
bite him but he's like now that's nice I
need a big snake to roll through his
anything
oh nice rat oh look at that small dog
and put a rat tail on goddamn it it
doesn't smell like bananas that's it rub
some more under my nose um they asked
him how he feels he shits on the floor
no no his nose in it that's aa way to
get him to stop he's been warned
so there's he swore my photographers the
press the sign goes up near his house
that told fans they were close to where
the living legend lived he received over
100 marriage proposals from women he'd
never met he's a real man there was even
a character on Gilligan's Island based
on him as like against [ __ ] yes it was
extremely racist once answered not
Gilligan's Island
it was extremely racist elegans Island
so the government did not look great in
this one because what their Ministry of
Defense and their armies had not been
able to do for almost 30 years was done
in five days by a 24 year old college
dropout with no tracking ability and he
wore sandals with socks yeah that's
what's that's a war crime that's a war
crime he Ronin Oda wasn't the only
soldier who stayed hidden after the war
there were a number of stories like this
but none as long so why was hero the
hero well there was a guy named Sochi
yokoi for instance and he was gone for
28 years in Guam but he hadn't kept
fighting like hero and he hadn't waited
to be relieved he was found by to hunt
and he was and it was viewed as he was
captured so when the two are compared
which they were a lot hero anata was by
far the more extort in 1975 hero went
into seclusion he moved to Brazil when
one of his brothers had relocated sure
he started a family of his own and ran a
cattle ranch his brother once said of
Heroes returned that he quote didn't
know whether to congratulate him or call
him an idiot well he's a [ __ ] idiot
he was left up there like we'll come for
you
I know but he's an idiot that's actually
for sure there's some signs they says we
got a lot of signs he's a cop a lot of
someone too - he got his he got a stone
Bros killed because he wouldn't [ __ ]
reel it in
yeah totally his fault with those guys
I'm not a doctor's guy's into it oh not
a died of heart failure combined with
pneumonia On January 16th 2014 in Tokyo
at the age of 91 so Japan did away with
their army after the war and they only
had a self-defence force which while it
is technically a military with branches
of the Army Navy and the Air Force is
not allowed to conduct any offensive
operations or leave Japan so this has
made some less fanatic about Heroes
story as time wore on but hopefully that
will all change because in 2014
Prime Minister Shinzo Abe a announced
the major revision to the SDF that Japan
would now be allowed to defend friends
and allies under attack for the first
time even if it was over seas here we go
here we go the coming for us
watch out Wars bad
where's bad that's what you take from
all war stories as war as [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah but this guy I mean I
think obviously it is you know it's
insane and he killed people and you know
50 to 100 yeah 50 100 a mass murderer
well but he was he was
he's got Bundy numbers yeah but Bundy
like he genuinely thought look from
being on the genuinely first of all the
the like the Japanese army was really
like vicious like even in when it would
come to like POWs like I think the
Germans killed something like you know 6
percent of POWs
like the Japanese killed like 27% like
during the war not really not they were
yeah so they were super like violent so
he was just sort of bred out of that and
yeah he is crazy for sure but uh you
know the whole time he's like they'll be
back tomorrow they'll be back tomorrow
yeah so that's the story of yeah but
when I like I'd heard the sleepin ants
yeah probably I mean or or you are the
opposite like if you hear banana or you
see like you're like the PERT there's
one person who's like scared of pickles
on Tyra Banks like you're that person
get that banana out here or he just
every time someone has a banana goes hey
I got a banana story for you guys like
oh my god so we could mix up a coconut
milk but the cow wasn't good and that's
when my friend cazuca died but I still
ate bananas even then could you believe
that
like he's the guy at the party where
you're just like oh yeah bad huh bananas
were been yeah okay you know it was
nineteen foot my first time I had a
penis for us to eat that went on for
almost thirty years and I'm gonna walk
you through each one now who are you
signaling nothing no one no one is just
I had an itch I know huh
oh he's still talking we're so party I
would move I would move to Brazil to I
would move to another country to get
away from it all but also he's a [ __ ]
dick yeah he also became like a
right-winger like he was like very he's
very militant believe it or not he was
but in his later life he was like we did
more army yeah of course he was head of
justify his whole [ __ ] existence in
the mountains which was a [ __ ]
existence no one knocking on heaven's
door do you at least make
like things to hang in and sleep in the
trees now no but some of their like
areas were pretty you know they look
nice after years I mean a for that long
like you're gonna have like a crib style
like welcome to our bamboo shelter oh
[ __ ] that guy alright North End
well this story's interesting but it's
been a solid [ __ ] or aramis he's an
ass clown that's not gonna be the title
bang